once you appreciate one of your one of
your blessings one of your Simpsons the
censored earring then you begin to
respect the sense of seeing and touching
and tasting you learn to respect all the
senses that's the late poet Maya Angelou
she was the first person featured in our
series note to self so far we have
featured more than 30 letters from
prominent figures who have written notes
to their younger selves the series is
the subject of our new book which is
also our first book from CBS this
morning it's called note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people it
will be published in May by Simon &
Schuster which by the way is a division
of CBS it'll feature 26 notes from
people like former Vice President Joe
Biden Oprah Tyler Perry Chelsea Handler
to name a few there's some really
wonderful observations in those notes
this I think so too
so if you sat down to write your own
note to self what would you write well
today we're inviting you to do just that
submit a letter to your younger self to
reflect on defining moments in your life
and the lessons you've learned it must
be an original letter 250 words or less
submissions will be accepted until April
20th and one might be featured here on
CBS this morning
you can enter right now just visit our
website CBS this morning
dot-com that's exciting I think so too
250 words you can say a lot